hey guys welcome to GameSpot universes
recap of walking dead season 7 episode 1
I'm buddy
that's Erin I'm here with Spencer and
Marko we're gonna talk about Walking
Dead some theories maybe a lot of
spoilers so let's get right into it so
guys the episode title is the day will
come when you won't be and that is
that's a reference to a season 1 dr.
Jenner quote where he lets the group out
of the CDC and says uh Rick says we're
grateful
dr. Jenner says the day will come when
you won't be and then he kills himself
meaning he opted out he was like dude
the world sucks and you're not gonna be
grateful for long this episode was the
day that Rick was no longer grateful I
think that's what that's pretty clever
it's kind of cool they were talking
about that what do you guys think this
episode suck no this episode was amazing
I loved every moment about this episode
and it really pays homage to that saying
and I think now with an introduction of
a new character and just the overall
presence of that character is really
gonna I think turn heads or bash him in
this case so whatever comes first
overall do you enjoy it it's good timing
I mean they were at a moment in time
when they could have been grateful for
something and the show wasn't gonna let
him get away with it they were almost
there
but then you know wouldn't be that
interesting of his Amba show if they
were just having a Sunday dinner I mean
the pacing of the episode was really
good
you were teased for like 15 minutes
straight like wondering who got killed
and then finally they like slowly reveal
he's still teasing you with every like
flashback that you get with Rick so Rick
that was probably one of my favorite
things as for the episode now I know why
they filmed all those deaths
yeah they filmed 11 deaths just just
because they didn't want it to be
spoiled they wanted to mess with people
they needed a lot of flashbacks for ramp
what do you think do you think that they
film the flashback scenes like knowing
they were gonna use them or do you think
they filmed them just to keep it but to
keep it under wraps well from the from
preview or sorry not the preview but
like the talking dead they talked that
they shot the episode back-to-back so I
think they had that in mind yeah but you
know some producer was there like you're
not gonna waste that footage I gotta pay
you actors I'm gonna get my money's
worth
some people that died in this episode do
you think that they were back to do a
corner based on who they could kill and
who they couldn't I think Abraham was
kind of an easy pick he kind of already
wanted to die in previous episodes and I
think he already knew his number was up
I think he was ready for it Glenn was
like it's weird like so he's a guy who
people have been expecting to die for a
while they were guys in the book yeah
like they weren't really sure when it
would happen I would have prefer to be a
little bit more glorious of the death
for him but yeah like so I guess he dies
in the breaking of Rick so conceptually
it makes sense they like they had to
kill somebody who would get to Rick what
do you think I don't know like I was
replaying that death and kind of trying
to get into this mind of why Daryl did
what he did to me it was like a kamikaze
like hit he knew that if he was gonna
hit he thought he knew if he were to hit
negan in the face that he was gonna die
I mean it that's the response that he
was just was showed by killing of
Abraham that's been the standard formula
of the bad guy in walk yeah dead up into
this point and then you get negan who is
obviously in that case media and Daryl's
heavy probably thought he was gonna be
sacrificing himself for the rest of the
group but he didn't understand group
dynamics with leaders and that's you
don't screw with the leader in front of
their crew or they're gonna have to show
you who's boss basically but like in a
twisted way like I'm not going after
Daryl like punishing him right away
that's like no we're gonna take somebody
else away from you and how's Daryl gonna
feel now that cuz now he's he's thinking
I'm responsible for now it's awful and
Ronin to the van he's thrown in the van
he's taken away from all his friends
he's injured still you know nians like
hey you know actually respect that guy
who just punched me in the face that's
why I'm gonna kill this other guy who I
don't know yet yeah so I I see negan as
a
most epic troll he's a mate he smiles
through things there's one scene when he
says guys we did it together
all of us especially with dead guys they
get an award for being like you know
like helping us get to this moment what
do you think
I mean negan is a he's a general who's
breaking another general you know he
walked into hilltop he killed one guy
and they're like we surrender cool give
you half our [ __ ] but like he knew this
crew was really dangerous he knew that
Rick was basically almost the same
quality as him so the reason that he
killed so many people and then he put
him through so much crap is cuz he had
to break another man who was like him
and like in a way if Rick was weak he
probably could have just killed one
person and that would have been the end
of it but he he like he wants it he said
it he wants a right-hand man and I think
he thinks Rick is a better right-hand
man than the one he's got so he invested
in him and he invested it him in like
the sickest possible way but he knew he
had to break him and everything that he
did was to break him and who stand who's
the thing that negan isn't afraid of
Rick in his own right
cuz yeah he messes with him
psychologically but the thing is that
when you think about it Rick's crew took
out so many of negan soldiers and
without a single loss of their own to
their own lines if you're negan
situation thinking wait a minute man I
don't know if I want to kill these
people I want him to work for me but I
have to set an example and I need to
break the leader I can't kill him
because if I do I'm gonna make him a
martyr and his guys are gonna you know
they're gonna revolt against me so what
better way you know break the body break
the spirit that's exactly what he he
accomplished in that episode I don't
think like negan was possible like
afraid I think he to me from what I got
from this episode and just only knowing
him from this episode I think he was
he's to I guess pompous or like
confident enough to like feel afraid and
at this point like revin though some of
his people died like I don't really
think he he I think to me he values them
to a point but not to be afraid of these
people like he just wanted to break this
person
and yeah I mean I think that there's
obviously something wrong with with with
me and he named his bat Lucille which is
the name of his dead wife that died of
cancer which is something you only find
out in the comic books up till now he
does things so differently like Rick if
there's a problem Rick kills it
rick has been a good leader rick has
been a crazy leader but Rick kills
problems like the dude in Episode six
that's like on negan let's make a boom
yeah so I think that I think it's it's
it's true that negan is certifiably
insane
but he also may may be a genius general
he's like a chess player he's I mean
yeah and he plans a few moves ahead
before he actually makes that move he's
like if I'm do this I might get result a
or might as well be cool but which one
I'm gonna choose it's up to you he's a
psychopath but I don't think he's insane
I think he knows exactly what he's doing
and why he's doing it like she gets that
killing is not the main purpose of war
it's breaking your enemies will and
killing is just a byproduct or a tool of
war so I mean that's what he did the
entire the entire end of last season all
he did was screw with them for an entire
day he was just breaking their wealth
that's all he was doing and honestly
like if they had broke at that point he
paced so to kill one person probably out
of just out of because that's his rule
and he wants to show he's serious but it
probably would've ended right there yeah
it goes back to the point of woody
killed him Daryl Hannah punched him here
yeah all right I want to mention
something before we get into predictions
for next episode and I mean even
subsequent didn't season episodes uh I
did not like the Sunday dinner thing I
don't think that it's even possible in
this world I get that in the back of all
their heads they might be thinking we're
gonna eat food and there's not gonna be
any zombies trying to kill us one day
will we use napkin holders I mean I'm
sure the availability of napkin holders
in this world is quite substantially
higher
I don't currently own a napkin holders
but if my neighbors are zombies they're
not gonna mind me taking them what did
you guys think about that dumb scene I
you know I liked it I liked it because
here's the thing it was more so the fact
it was it was more sort of a send-off
for those two characters that got killed
because you do
you do see them sitting next to each
other you do see them you know he's
holding his son and Glenn holding his
son and then you have Abraham there
they're all trying to it's what they
would have wanted and it's called hope
and that's kind of thing that keeps them
going in this whole ordeal is the fact
that we're trying to recover what we
used to have and the fact that now
that's all gone I love the fact how
negan's voice was being played over that
that was great that was so great because
you're thinking you're trying to picture
this what they could have had but now
there's negan's voice like no it's not I
just Ramallah Tov cocktail that dinner
so it's over now but it was great I'd
liked it I mean they yeah they were
talking about again like at the end of
last season they were almost at that
point where that would have been
possible and that has now been taken
away from them although like I don't
know what happens after you work for
negan cuz hilltop actually was doing
okay they weren't doing great but like
negan wasn't showing up and killing
somebody every day so I don't know it's
like could still happen - to people that
sucks but maybe like I don't know if it
could still happen like in that sense if
like negan's
taking over your place and making you
work but I mean I liked that that little
ending send-off for them I don't think I
didn't meet Meighan and they were
rebuilding Alexandria I think that was
possibility I really think because they
were they were coming off strong wiping
out all those zombies right and like
reclaiming Alexandria so I believe that
that is still a possibility if they can
get through the sneaking max I just had
a thought that the name the Savior's is
truly in itself oh my gosh he's such a
troll alright predictions real quick
what do you think who's gonna who's
gonna kill who is the war happening soon
is it happening next season this season
what do you think do you think Rick's
gonna bring it next episode well I know
that we've seen some trailers with
Ezekiel's character and marker can speak
a little bit more to that but I think
you're setting up for medieval kingdoms
fighting each other at this stage I mean
basically everybody's been set back to
medieval times my
the few firearms that are left over with
assault rifles yeah was I mean yeah but
their place their places in the world
that are like that like this some places
the Middle East its medieval times with
ak-47s right yep so like your school
yeah you're setting yourself up for for
medieval I think we're fair I think Rick
is on as of right now as we just saw
Rick is is broken he has to obey to this
not because he wants to but because he
knows that there are a lot of things at
stake here but I think one more push
someone dying close to him he's
Parkinson wealthy I'd say we're going to
war we're gonna do this and who knows
what's really going on maybe because
negan is gathering people not just for
supplies but you could be gathering it
for a possible attack on another group
that may just be as big if not bigger
than his because if these people are as
dangerous as they are why would you want
to keep them alive and more importantly
why do you want them to join their ranks
besides gathering supplies so it could
be they could be arming themselves they
could he could easily give out like a
patent speech and a few episodes later
down the road saying listen we're not
the only ones out there and if you want
to live this group over there they're
just as strong they're gonna take our
stuff let's get them so who knows there
could be I really like what's gearing up
for this season and so yeah I don't
think negan's going away in one season
it's I see it as like a multiple seasons
maybe two or three because he's such a
big character and like a turning point
for this like series in this one episode
they're gonna need a lot of help if
they're gonna go into war and it got
presented through multiple previews with
the Ezekiel character with a badass
tiger right next to him but it seemed
like that community from the previews
was like very closed off and we don't
know if negan has any like view like
they know about that place at all but
Rick's gonna need to band together
multiple like groups in order to fight
negan's crew especially how they like
you put it out there and how they toyed
with them last season I mean we got a
little sense of how big their crew is so
they're gonna need to match that and I
don't see that happening in just one
season I think another thing to that's
interesting is that who knows what's
going on between Meghan's ranks because
aside from the Psychopaths that are just
as messed up as he is there I'm willing
to bet there are a lot of people who in
like Rick's situation we have to work
for him but who's to say that they're
not waiting for someone like a leader to
take over like say Rick or more
importantly Maggie who just lost her
husband and now she's the first person
in the whole group despite everything
that happened said we need to get him
how girl power is that that's super
awesome
can you imagine really taking all right
taking out the group yeah that's the be
on the imagine heard like sending up the
messages within negan's ranks saying
that week we can fight this guy he's
just one messed up dude like we could
take him and that would be that would be
huge I think that would be a really cool
segment for her to be you know you took
away everything for me now I'm gonna do
the same to you so I mean but if you're
gonna fight [ __ ] you need an army so
their crew needs an army or needs to
join an army hmm but who's to say she
can't move in there and start taking
people out of his army to join her group
where is that how am I gonna come from
guys is it gonna be Ezekiel that saves
everybody is the problem going to be
resolved within negan zone rank is Rick
gonna rise up and use the six-shooter
that we all know and love them for find
out next year possibly we're gonna be
next episode is called the well I have
no insight into what that means as of
yet but we're gonna talk about it join
us nerd out with us keep it locked to
GameSpot universe for your favorite
comic books TV shows and movies I'm
buddy Aaron Spencer
Marco we'll see you guys next week